[Music]
hey it's Dan
welcome to another edition of the 10%
happier podcast my guest this week is a
guy I met a couple years ago shortly
after my book came out it came into my
office interviewed me I had no idea it
was such a big deal but now I do
his name is rich roll and he is you may
have heard of him he's got a very
popular podcast he's also an author and
an ultra endurance athlete am i putting
that correctly that's fairly correct
what's the absolute correct way to say
it well the big deal part I don't know
about that that would be a deal part is
it but ultra endurance athlete is yeah
that's correct and and also you do all
this while being plant-based in other
words you're a vegan
so a lot of people wonder how can you
exert yourself the way in the ways in
which you do well eating no meat which
we'll get to but I want to start with
the question I always start with which
is are you a meditator and if so how did
you get there and why I am a meditator
I've had an interesting kind of
relationship with meditation and
evolving relationship with meditation I
think my first introduction to
meditation was in rehab where I lived
for a hundred days when I was 31 years
old and what were you coming off of
alcohol yeah I had a interesting descent
into the depths of alcoholism that took
me to some pretty dark places throughout
my 20s I was lucky enough to hit that
bottom and surrender to the problem that
I was having and sought out help and
went to rehab in Oregon where I lived
for a hundred days and that was my first
introduction to many things a toolbox
for how I live my life today but one of
them is meditation which is part of the
12 steps and I can't say that it really
stuck they listened a prayer or
meditation right right exactly so what
did they teach you they don't really
teach you much of anything they just
sort of say this is part of it and it
kind of gets brushed over I think in my
opinion now with what I know about
meditation and
how impactful it has been in my life
it's certainly a component of sobriety
in that construct but I would say that
it's under emphasized but I but that was
the first you know introduction and then
after that I started going to yoga
classes and was introduced to it a
little bit more through that medium but
it never became a regular practice or a
priority for me until recent years and
it really came through doing my podcast
and interviewing meditation teachers and
practitioners friends of mine and it
just became very clear to me that this
was a blind spot that I really needed to
incorporate into my life and since then
it has incrementally grown into a
priority and something that I take
pretty seriously now and have found to
be extremely beneficial can you give me
a sense of what your practice is I keep
it really simple I don't get too
dogmatic about it and I don't get too
caught up in technique I really just try
to focus on the breath and and stay out
of sort of the self judgment but I think
trips up a lot of people how's that gone
for you yeah it's up and down you know
what I mean like I get you know two
seconds of peace and then you know the
mind intervenes once again as it always
does but rather than beat myself a
second but yeah I know well that that's
after years of doing this right and just
try to continually you know release it
release it release it and bring it back
to the breath and hopefully
incrementally get a little bit better
and you know I've noticed the benefits
in many ways in my life and so you know
I believe in it strongly and I think
part of my evolution was for for many
years as an ultra endurance athlete like
I spend a lot of time in solitude
training like lots of hours on the bike
really long runs and there's a there's a
certainly an active meditation component
to that and I've gotten a lot of benefit
out of that and for many years I sort of
said well that's my meditation and I
think a lot of all that all the ayats
and my wife who
a much more avid and experienced
meditator than myself would constantly
say that's great rich but like I think
you really are missing the bigger
picture here there's something to a
structured formalized meditation
practice that is qualitatively different
from what you're experiencing when
you're training and I would tell her
yeah but you don't know what I'm doing
like you know you don't understand but
when I actually committed to doing a
formal meditation practice I realized
the difference and so I'm always quick
to point that out to the many athletes
that I going to speak with yeah can I
give my little shtick on this I don't
think it's not for you it's for anybody
who's listening because I've been
mapping out with some colleagues of mine
from the 10% happier app company like
all the reasons that people give for not
meditating and one of them is blank is
my meditation running is my meditation
gardening is my meditation petting my
dog is my meditation I don't need to
meditate some are doing this thing and
my answer to that is maybe depends how
you're doing it like if you run the way
I run which is that you're rehearsing
all the stuff you're going to save your
boss or you're listening to a podcast or
listening to music planning a murder
whatever that is not meditation if you
are running and your headphones are out
and you're feeling your footfalls you're
feeling the wind on your face
you're feeling the motion of your body
and then every time you get distracted
you start again whether you're
meditating right I don't know many
people actually run like that or garden
like that or pet their dog like that and
if and if you do then great then blankie
is your meditation but if you don't then
a formal seated practice might be
something you want yeah and and
conversely if you're sitting in lotus
position and your your fingers are in
the right place and you have your mala
beads in your hand but you're rehearsing
what you're going to say to your boss
that's probably not meditation either
manifestly not meditation absolutely
however I think it really on that one
just the only thing I'd say because I
don't want people to hear that and say
well I sit and I in whatever visit you
know you can sit whatever position you
want just for the record you don't have
to sit in a lotus position you can sit
in the chair but a lot of people sit and
feel completely distracted they do find
themselves
rehearsing arguments with their boss or
planning lunch or whatever as long as
and is the only ingredient that needs to
be added there is the intention to focus
on your breath or whatever your
objective meditation is and then every
time you get lost start again so don't
feel guilty
listeners viewers whatever if you find
yourself can't just get extracted a
million times because that's the whole
game as you said when you eloquently
described your own practice I would
agree with that
thank you thank you so so this has been
a couple of years of a really sustained
serious practice on your end yeah I
would say about three years two and a
half years and what kind of I want to
hear about the impact in your life and
I'm just going to pick one narrow area
first which is on your athletics has it
had an impact on your performance yeah
absolutely absolutely I think the
biggest impact that it's had is the
ability to anchor yourself in the
present moment
so when and and to become the observer
of your thinking mind and I'm sure you
talk about this all the time but the
thinking mind is very good at certain
things but it's probably most skilled at
talking you out of whatever it is you're
attempting to do or you know the
self-defeating thoughts like I have a
lot of insecurities and a lot of
anxieties and and those inevitably crop
up and when you're whether you're
training or you're racing and I'm in
these extended you know incredibly long
races that I do it's it's impossible to
not have that moment where where
everything everything in your mind and
your body is telling you to stop it's
giving you all the reasons this is Ubud
why you doing this you can be at home
with your kids you could be eating a
cheaper exactly
well not the cheeseburger and to be to
be able to distinguish that from your
higher consciousness and to understand
that this is just the chatter of the
idle mind and that you actually have the
ability the the ability to discern the
difference and make a decision even if
it's just that like extra little moment
to understand that so that you're not
reactive and you can actually
contemplate an appropriate response and
anchor yourself back into the present
moment and move forward and go how old
you know if you don't mind I just turned
50 you look good
so are you how are you still how far can
you run at age 50 can my knees blown out
from running on a treadmill I can run
pretty far I would say I haven't raced
since 2011 so my training kind of was
very intense from around 2007 to 2011
and then since then it's been about
podcasting and talking to people like
you and writing books and travel and the
like but turning 50 I've now kind of
refocused I want to have a performance
goal for this year so I'm doing a big
race in September so I've actually just
gotten back into some pretty structured
serious training and it's starting to
ramp up because I want to see what I can
do at 50 what does that mean it's a race
like when you say a race is that like
you're going to run in 5k what are you
talking about well the race I'll set the
stage by providing some context the race
that I specialized in in the past in is
a race called Ultraman which is a double
Ironman distance triathlon it's a
three-day 320 miles circumnavigation of
the Big Island of Hawaii
that's ridiculous which is ridiculous
yeah it is yeah and I've done very well
in that race I'm not an Ultraman I'm
like whatever the opposite of oh yo man
is couch man your ultraman in your own
world know what I mean in no world am I
an ultimate I thought anyway I'm a big
you know I give you your proper so and
that race is like the first day you you
swim 6.2 miles and then ride your bike
90 miles the second day you ride your
bike 171 miles and the third day you
celebrate this whole ridiculous affair
by running 50 2.4 miles a double
marathon so that's pretty far I haven't
done anything like that in a couple
years the race that I'm doing in
September is this really bizarre people
die doing this I mean people don't die
it's amazing you it's it's actually
really inspiring to watch there are
people do this race and there's a lot of
older people that do it it's really cool
do you count yourself now as older or do
you mean even older I guess there are
people that are that are older than me
that do it I'm not making funny
you by the way because I'm 445 so we're
almost the same and we're the same yeah
face it the race that I'm doing in
September is called Otello and it's in
Sweden and it is a it's the World
Championships of something called swim
run which is a big deal in Europe
nobody's ever heard of it in the United
States but it's a very long like a
nine-hour race over the course of the
day you end up running about 40 miles
and swimming about seven miles but
there's 52 transitions so you're in the
kind of archipelago south of Stockholm
and you you're swimming across these
waterways and then climbing up these
rocks and running across these little
islands and then jumping back in the
water and swimming and and and literally
changing it up the whole time so you're
doing the whole thing and like this
modified wetsuit with your running shoes
on like you leave your running shoes on
while you're swimming and you're
tethered to a teammate so you do it as a
duo like in pairs are you blindfolded or
any did you raise your hair together
like what anything else you can do to
increase the degree of difficulty yeah I
don't know like it's a new world for me
I'm still learning about it and it
scares me which is why I'm excited to do
it but I'll let you know back in
September after I do it first person on
the spot gets to use the word
archipelago so good that was on I'll
always have that you will so so other
areas of your life I mean you have how
many kids you have three four kids for
what are their ages 22 2013 and nine so
how has meditation impacted your family
life I would say that it's similar to
it's a similar it's similar to how it's
improved my athletics really I think
it's it's about being able to be present
in whatever you're doing to be able to
show up and actually be there as opposed
to you know sort of being distracted all
the time so for example you know there
can be you can be a stay-at-home mom or
dad but if you're sort of on your phone
the whole time that you're with your
kids or you're reading the newspaper or
anxious or you know caught up in your
mind about other things that are bugging
you then how present are you really so
for me it's allowed me to you know flick
that switch and really be where I'm at
in whatever capacity that is as a
parents as partner to my wife etc also
to be able to not get caught up in you
know the drama that inevitably occurs
when you know siblings are not getting
along or stuff your kids are doing it
you're not happy with so you're not
being reactive to that and you're able
to sort of contemplate the appropriate
parenting response for kids is ambitious
I mean I've got one and he's like you
ever see that movie with a Jurassic
world or they make a dinosaur in the lab
was we made him in the lab because he
was an IVF baby and then he turns out to
be a complete jerk the dinosaur and then
destroys everything that's a little bit
like what's happening well it's been a
trick it's been fun it's been a try you
know but the two older ones are my
wife's boys from a previous marriage
so I'm their stepdad but they've lived
with me since they were three and four
years old and their father has since
passed away and then two little girls
that my wife and I had together it's
adorable so can you tell me a little bit
you told me this offline but and I know
you give speeches about this but it tell
us a little bit about your story of how
you became this endurance athlete
because you're as you you reference it a
little bit earlier but you weren't
living the healthiest lifestyle for much
of your early years right so so I had
this struggle with drugs and alcohol
throughout my 20s I got sober at 31 and
you know I was somebody that as a young
person had a lot of promise
like I graduated top of my class in high
school I got in every college I applied
to I went to Stanford I was a world
ranked swimmer I competed on to NC to a
division 1 championship teams you know I
had the world by the tail at one point
and I squandered a lot of those
opportunities as a result of my you know
issues with substance and so when I got
sober I became very intent upon
repairing all the wreckage that I
created as a result of my drinking and
using and I sort of threw all of my
addictive tendencies and obsessive
compulsive behavior patterns in
my work into my profession to try to you
know prove to myself that I could repair
this and also to the world into society
and so I kind of chased this American
dream and I was a corporate lawyer on
the partnership and you know I was I was
successful in that regard so by the time
I was 39 you know successful attorney
partnership track you know nice sports
car in the driveway you know it met my
wife building a family lived in a really
nice home and so I mean II drove because
it is a plot twist coming before we get
into that what what was under girding
the the problems with drugs and alcohol
and then the the kind of diversionary
addiction tactic that you took in your
30s of throwing all of that into into
your professional ambition what was what
was going on in your mind that made all
that happen it's kind of the $64,000
question you know why are you an
alcoholic and you know I try not to
spend too much time trying to parse that
because I don't know what benefit that
avails me you know is it genetic is it
something that happened to me when I was
a kid you know I don't know the answer
to that I do know that I was one of
those kids who was insecure and kind of
a loner had difficulty making friends
always felt like I was separate from and
I sat you know I had I just I felt like
everybody had the rulebook for life and
I didn't yeah but I mean I I find that
so surprising because because if you to
meet you now at 50 you're like we were
very cool yeah I was out a little kid no
very nerdy kid you know okay I was very
much you know different I would say and
I think drug and alcohol helped me you
know the help that helped give me social
skills initially it starts out as fun
you know it works in the beginning it
brought me out of my shell suddenly I
could go to parties I could talk to
girls I could crack jokes and it was
like all good for a period of time and
that's why you do more and you do more
but you know it turned dark for me it
started to you know erode my ambitions
and it really broke my instincts and you
know made me do things that I would not
ordinarily do
and really you know at the end it was it
was bad I was I was a around-the-clock
drinker really acha tonic in the shower
sneaking drinks throughout the day Wow
you know it was bad and when I was in
rehab one of the counselors said you
know after it like when I went to rehab
I finally told people what I was
actually doing is this is like my big
secret even though everybody knew I was
no colic I knew I was an alcoholic for a
long time before I got sober they said
yeah you know rich like you have a
pretty progressed case of alcohol like
you usually see this in sixty
five-year-old lifelong drinkers like
this is a serious thing like because
when I showed up in rehab I thought I
was going to do a spin dry and you know
a couple weeks and just get back to my
job and they were like yeah we think you
should stick around and that's why I
ended up staying for such a long period
of time like I got it good for you for
getting it yeah and you know it hasn't
been easy and it hasn't been a linear
progression of growth either but it did
save my life and and you know to this
day sobriety is my number one priority
and I'm very active in the in the
recovery community but you know to kind
of get back to that to get back to the
story so you know I still have I'm still
an extreme I've always been an extreme
personality I was in my swimming career
I was academically and that's just how
I'm wired for better or worse so
throwing myself into that kind of
workaholism you know worked to the
extent that it progressed my career but
I never took a beat to sort of consider
what was that I actually wanted to do I
was so obsessed with just being viewed
in the eyes of society as somebody who
was successful and responsible so I kind
of chased this you know legal
partnership thing without really taking
a minute to decide whether that was
actually something I really wanted so by
the time I was 39 and meanwhile you know
I stopped taking care of myself
physically so I became kind of a junk
food addict I put on 50 pounds and on
the inside I was I was kind of depressed
like a couch potato you know starts
sliding into middle age on a crash
course with with chronic lifestyle
illness
and so shortly before I turn 40 I had
this moment where this kind of
existential crisis that I was harboring
crashed into a health scare where I was
walking up a flight of stairs to go to
sleep late one night and I had to pause
I was winded and out of breath and had
tightness in my chest and sweat on my
brow and really felt like I was on the
precipice of having a heart attack it
was a very frightening moment and it was
very similar to the day that I decided I
was finally going to get sober like a
very crystallized moment in time where I
realized like I'm having that experience
again and I have an opportunity to
really change my life and so I was able
to like I had the cognizance to
understand that this is a special moment
and I really grabbed onto it and that
was the beginning of trying to
course-correct how I was living so did
you quit the law firm what happened not
overnight you know I started playing
around with diet and nutrition to try to
find a way of eating that would allow my
body to heal itself and feel better and
that was not a overnight process either
I was trying everything I did juice
cleanse I tried a bunch of different
diets and really stumbled into eating
plant-based as a last resort after
trying everything else and not finding
success and when I went completely 100%
plant-based like no animal products no
processed foods in a very short period
of time like a week to ten days I sell
unbelievably better I had more energy
than I had since I was like a teenager
and I realized I had kind of backed into
something that perhaps could be quite
profound and started to educate myself
about diet nutrition and with that came
a desire to sort of take care of myself
physically again and I had an impulse
and a desire to get fit once again to
exercise which I hadn't felt in many
years and that was a gradual process of
just you know going outside and jogging
a little bit I didn't have aspirations
to return to competitive athletics in my
40s I really just wanted to lose the gut
around my midsection and be able to
enjoy my kids at their energy level but
with each kind of successive week that
went by I was enjoying
more and more and the pounds kind of
melted away and I was experiencing you
know like this this joy that I hadn't
felt since I was like a kid you know
when I loved swimming and I just wanted
more and more of that and I made a
decision that I was going to follow that
impulse like it was I was starting to
unpack like the you know what it was
about me that just made me happy in a
very simple primal way and I decided to
listen to that instead of repressed that
and just do kind of what society
expected me to do meanwhile I'm
practicing law and I'm doing all that
kind of stuff but ultimately I ended up
quitting the big law firm I started a
little practice with a couple friends
and started to have a little bit more
agency over my time and in a very short
period of time I felt like I had I was
starting to morph into this different
person like a completely different
person who was more comfortable in my
own skin living more kind of authentic
to who I was and it was so profound that
it kind of led me to this question of
human possibility and potential because
of a period of like maybe six months I
went from like this 50 pound overweight
couch potato guy into a somebody who was
really excited about being outdoors and
going out on a trail at dawn and feeling
slim and in my body again and I wanted
to extort what it did was it made me
realize that I had all these blind spots
about what I'm actually capable of and I
wanted to explore the outer perimeters
of that and when I found out about this
world of ultra endurance sports that
just fascinated me and it seemed like a
perfect template to kind of explore that
for myself so I think I mean there's a
way in which your story as amazing as it
is could be whittled down to a bit of a
cliche of just you know follow your
dream and I suspect that some people
listening to this are like well you know
I don't have the luxury to do what this
dude did I can't you know quit my job
and start running all over the world so
what do you say to people who listen
your story and say art well
that's for some other people not me yeah
it's a great question
and I actually you know went through
kind of a financial dismantling as we
underwent this transformation actually
as a family really so it wasn't easy I
would say to anybody who who has that
reaction that it's not about quitting
your job and following you know it's not
about like making these radical
overnight changes I think that we all
have untapped reservoirs of potential
and I think we have blind spots when it
comes to things that make us happy and I
would encourage anybody who's listening
to kind of conjure up or try to
reminisce or remember things that gave
them joy as a child and to the extent
that those are things that one does not
do anymore for whatever reason that
there's always a way to to express those
in your life and it doesn't have to mean
quitting your job like if you like
playing the banjo when you were 12 or
you like writing jokes then maybe
there's a way to go and do an open mic
night or to take a guitar lesson or do
that thing find a way in your free time
to explore that part of you that is
under expressed but ultimately you know
fundamental component of who you are and
what brings you happiness so how serious
do you get about the the Athletics how
far did you go with it in in the ultra
render yeah yeah I got pretty serious
about it yeah I got pretty serious about
it
I hired a coach I got it I learned about
this race ultra man and I became
obsessed and I was like I've got to find
a way to do this race like a switch was
flick and this illogical impulse kind of
took hold of me and I just knew I had to
find a way to toe the line at that race
for whatever reason it made no logical
sense whatsoever well your wife's a bus
and she was always really supportive
she's like go for it that's fantastic
and she knew that I was struggling and
suffering and she saw that this was a
way for me to it was like a journey to
wholeness like it really was it
really was a spiritual adventure for me
of trying to reconnect with with myself
in a profound way so she always had my
back and I could have never done any of
the things that I've done without her
support but yeah I got really intense I
mean at its most intense I was training
upwards of twenty five hours a week so
it almost became like a job and I was
juggling practicing law at the time and
so I can remember being out on a long
train long training rides and my phone
would ring and I would pull over to the
side of the road and I would negotiate
some deal with clients and other lawyers
and I'd be like if they could see where
what I'm actually doing right now they
wouldn't believe it so it was a bit of a
tightrope back for a little while until
I kind of came out of the closet with
what I was actually doing but yeah I
took it very seriously and because I
wanted to be able to do it and say I
gave it everything I got to see what I
was actually capable of doing and so
what is your professional portfolio
consists of now now I stopped practicing
law in 2012 when my first book came out
finding ultra and I just cut the cord
completely because I'd been weaning
myself off of it for some time but it
was always like this lifeline you know
the phone would ring and I could do a
deal or represent some client and and I
knew that if I didn't completely cut
that cord that I would always go back to
it and I wanted to be able to just
completely jump into the abyss so today
my life consists of doing my podcast and
traveling for public speaking writing
books I've got a few products on my site
I've got some online courses and the
like and just basically being an
advocate at large for healthy living
your job is to be rich rolled they said
I said it's a good job yeah nobody else
alright nobody can take it away from me
so let's talk about veganism where you
prefer plant-based diet that's another
one that people hear and think I can't
get there I think personally no because
I and I've talked about this on the show
before like I
I would like to do it on many levels I
know what's holding me back mostly just
to say mostly because of animal cruelty
I mean that to me is the the biggest
motivator I don't know that it would
have some sort of I've eaten very close
to vegan on if not full-on vegan on
lengthy meditation retreats and I didn't
notice any sort of major physical change
I eat reasonably healthy as it is but
what's holding me back I would have it
would have to I really would have to get
my wife on board and I think she feels
very strongly to about animal cruelty
and we just haven't been able to do it
and we have I think the real issue is we
haven't made it a priority frankly we
talked about it we both agree on ethical
grounds that the case is really strong
we just haven't made it a priority
mm-hmm do you cook at home I do not as
much as I should I make at home
smoothies including smoothies from your
cookbook and also a smoothie that you
just one day when you were in my office
told me I should have which is spinach
kale banana blueberry and I add avocado
and it's delicious even though it
sounded disgusting to me at the time I
also make just you know peanut butter
almond milk Greek yogurt yogurt part and
bananas um for my kid and he loves it so
and I you know I cook yeah I do a little
bit of cooking it right but you have a
cook you have our cookbook yeah you send
it to me all right
okay yeah all right so so what's holding
you back sounds like it's it's
prioritization yeah laziness and inertia
right right right
it's interesting also like my wife I
couldn't do it without I don't think I
could just start yeah I understand yeah
I understand you know I think it's a
it's a leap of faith for people once you
kind of make that commitment though and
step over the line living in New York
City it's so easy to do you know so not
easy it wouldn't be easy I think you'd
be surprised every dinner I have with
friends would be a discussion I'm sure
when you go out to eat with friends as
well you're in LA and you move
wellness circle so it's really fine well
yeah like now I'm like everybody knows
it's not a big deal but at first I'm
sure it was a massive pain in the
you-know-what it can be there's a lot of
mental projection about that though that
ends up being not as challenging as you
might imagine you know travelled all
over the world in restaurants all the
time I've never had an issue making it
work where there's a will is away and
there's you know there's there's certain
social graces that you learn to how to
navigate it
because the last thing I want to be in a
restaurant as the pain-in-the-ass guy
who's like you know making a stink and
drawing attention to himself and you
know sometimes I'll just excuse myself
from the dinner table and go find the
waiter and say hey can you just like
make me the biggest sell you've ever
seen or just you know do you know throw
together a bunch of vegetables on some
rice and and and that way you go back to
the table and you don't you realize like
people you think everyone's judging you
and looking at you people are
self-obsessed they don't really care
they're thinking about them so
absolutely know what I mean a friend
this is just a so somewhat of a tangent
bitter I think that's such a great point
a former boss of mine who had endured a
few sort of tough public trials where
you know he had there were scandals
would be too strong a word but he had he
had to endure some stuff where things
were written about him that he didn't
like and he said going through that is
like being seasick to you it feels like
the world is ending everybody else it's
like mildly amusing right and it's true
we're all in the stars of our own movie
you know we were only like sort of
mildly interested in other people's
thing so you're right I guess you're
there's a mental projection going on on
my end on the social aspect of veganism
but here's the thing when you when you
break it down and you really look at it
it's it's kind of an amazing lifestyle
because right now we're in the midst of
this insane healthcare crisis you know
something like 70% of Americans are
overweight or obese one out of every
three people are going to die of heart
disease they're projecting that by 2030
50% of American learning to be diabetic
or pre-diabetic 75% of
health care costs are attributable to
these chronic lifestyle illnesses and
the truth is if you go plant-based you
can basically opt out of becoming one of
those statistics and it's an amazing way
to not succumb to these diseases that
are killing millions and millions of
people meanwhile you know animal
agriculture is we're basically which is
like the number one culprit when it
comes to almost every single man-made
environmental ill on the planet more
greenhouse gas emissions than all
transportation combined you know it's
it's wreaking havoc on our planet so
there's the environmental concern
there's the ethical considerations that
are important to you and there's the
health considerations and I don't know
of any other lifestyle that can like
check all of those boxes it's really
profound it's really profound it's
beautiful way to live more sustainably
on this planet and from kind of a
meditation perspective it's you know
there's there's less sort of karmic toll
yeah and and it and it just feels good
to live that way it's not about being on
a pulpit and judging anyone else for
their lifestyle decisions it's a
personal choice but I can tell you that
you know I got into it for personal
health reasons I just didn't want to be
fat I don't want to be lazy and now the
environmental concerns and the ethical
concerns have taken the forefront and
you know are of primary interest in me
it was the one class I remember when we
had you can in my office to interview me
for your podcast many years ago and and
I'm so I'm taking credit for you
launching a podcast yes you should
actually look really five you came with
these fancy little mics and I was like
wow this looks like fun and now look at
this
yes I'm sure we're in ideaa dreaming
unbelievable it is I work for Disney so
we have a few resources but what I
remember when we turned the mics off I
asked you a bunch of questions about
veganism because this is just something
that is really been in the back of my
head for a long time and one of the
questions I asked was how do you I mean
if you are you getting enough protein to
be able to perform at the level you need
and just could you repeat what you said
to me yeah there's so so many
misconceptions
options about protein and a lot of it is
driven by marketing forces because when
you go to the grocery store it looks
like every packaged food product in bold
capital letters will tell you how much
protein is in the product and it's
almost impossible from a consumer
perspective to not kind of intuitively
take away from that that well we must
need tons of protein like if I don't
drink a protein shake within moments of
waking up in the morning how am I going
to possibly breathe air in and out of my
lungs the truth of the matter is that we
actually don't need that much protein
about 10% of calories when you're
talking about protein you're really
talking about amino acids the building
blocks of protein I wish the word
protein didn't even exist and we were
just talking about amino acids and what
we really need are the nine essential
amino acids which are the ones that our
bodies cannot synthesize on our own we
need to get them from foods but turns
out they're in copious amounts in all
kinds of plant foods if you randomly
graze on plants all day long you'll be
hard-pressed to not meet your daily
recommended allowance of protein and
I've been doing this for 10 years I'm
150 like I said I can still go out and
kill it with the best of them I've never
had any problems building lean muscle
mass or recovering in between workouts
so I think the whole thing is a big red
herring and and it's just not something
that we need to really be concerned
about or focused on the truth is that no
doctors are treating patients for a
protein deficiency although we all think
we're not getting enough protein what we
really should be talking about is fiber
most people are not getting enough fiber
in their diet and you know I just think
that we need to really take a look at
this obsession that we have with protein
and understand that it is misplaced
there are plenty of amazing accomplished
plant-based athletes out there more and
more every day and you know it's easy
for me to say skinny long-distance
runner guy but there are MMA fighters
and boxers and bodybuilders and power
lifters and you know athletes where
speed and agility and force and strength
are
paramount importance and they're all
tell you the same thing the recovery is
better they're less prone to get injured
and as an athlete recovery is like the
Holy Grail the faster you can recover in
between workouts the harder you can
train and when you Pro track that out
over a course of a season or a number of
years you see tremendous performance
gains plus we have these gigantic large
herbivore animals you know like the
Rhino and the you know the gorilla these
are these are herbivores and they're
able to build tremendous strength eating
just plants and I think there's
something to be learned from that with
people want to learn more about you how
can they do so what are the what are the
place where should we go what should we
read etcetera etcetera we want to know
more about retro my website rich roll
comm is the best place my podcast is the
rich world podcast you can find it on
itunes or wherever you listen to this
podcast and I'm just a tree troll on
Twitter and Instagram I'm pretty easy to
find on in the books my book is called
finding ultra it's my memoir and then
the cookbook is called the plant power
way plant power way right that's right
it's in our kitchens yeah
such a pleasure to have you on man
thanks for having me I really appreciate
it it was really fun how are we going to
get you vegan what do we need to do I
think every conversation like this I had
Matt to your record on recently uh-huh
also got in my head about this so it's
it's it's in there percolate eight it's
percolating in a very powerful way so
this has been very useful yeah cool
their leadership and thanks to everybody
is listening or watching because we're
live-streaming this and if you want to
rate us or review us or subscribe we
always appreciate that ef5 stars if
you're going to rate us and if you want
to learn how to meditate you check out
the 10% happier app we'll see you next
time thank you
you
[Music]